[Music]
on this friday night
is a vaccine shortage looming we need
more vaccines the pleas to protect more
canadians from covet 19 as ontario's
caseload hits
an all-time high efforts to restrict
president trump's access to the nuclear
codes
and get him impeached a second time
britain's
deadliest day of the pandemic the virus
is out of control
walk some students to find nurses crying
the kovic crisis pushes london hospitals
to the brink
and one year after flight ps752 was shot
down
i driving a lot during the night because
i can't sleep
loved ones of those killed struggle to
cope with the heartbreaking loss
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with the impact of the pandemic
on canadians there are multiple warning
signs the weeks ahead could be worse
than anything we've seen since the
coronavirus
first arrived in canada a year ago case
counts are rising and more canadians are
becoming seriously ill
more than four thousand canadians are in
the hospital with covid19 right now
over 800 of them are in critical care an
average of 136 deaths are being reported
every day ontario smashed its daily case
record today
more than 4 200 new cases a record 369
people are in
intensive care in ontario 250 of them
on ventilators this is
so so serious matter of fact this is the
most serious situation
we've ever been in ever ever since the
beginning of this pandemic
it's a sign public health restrictions
are not working premier ford said
further measures are
coming but he didn't spell out when or
whether they'll include closing
non-essential businesses and imposing
a curfew that's what quebec has done the
four-week lockdown and curfew begins
there tomorrow
manitoba has extended its strict
lockdown for another two weeks
and alberta's top doctors said today the
first case of the south african variant
of cobit 19 has been detected in alberta
she says it's a recent traveler who is
in quarantine
and there's no evidence at this time the
mutated virus has spread to others
there is news tonight too about vaccines
some premiers are warning about a
looming shortage and the federal
government says it's trying to
accelerate
deliveries david aiken has our top story
tonight
all i need is vaccines if there's one
thing the federal government can do and
they're trying
they're trying their best we need more
vaccines
ontario's premier is not the only one
pleading for more doses
everyone is in toronto a clinic run by
the university health network or uhn
was set to exhaust its vaccine supply
friday
we will then have used up all of the
stock that's available for the clinic
at uhn and uh unfortunately we have many
many more
staff who are anxious to be inoculated
the problem
ottawa's ability to supply vaccines will
not
catch up to the province's ability to
administer vaccines
for weeks this initial phase of phase
one
is characterized by a limited and steady
supply of vaccines for much of january
february and march
before we see a significant ramp up
leading into april
canada should get 6 million doses by the
end of march but
that's only enough to inoculate 3
million canadians because
both moderna and pfizer biontech are two
dose vaccines and
officials say it is crucial to reserve
that second dose
as per the manufacturer's
recommendations in terms of getting
to that peak effectiveness levels you do
need the second dose to pick up the pace
of vaccine distribution
some of the vaccine candidates already
purchased by the government
have to get health canada approval and
if that does not happen
the government will not hit its target
of inoculating everyone in canada who
wants a vaccine
by september so the numbers that we are
using for our predictions
are based on the assumption that the
vaccines that we have procured
will indeed be approved by health canada
health canada is looking at new vaccines
from astrazeneca
and johnson and johnson and even though
the uk has
already approved astrazeneca's it may
not be until the end of
february before canadian regulators are
able to approve
any new vaccines david aiken global news
ottawa we'll get back to the pandemic in
a moment but the other big story tonight
is what's developing in washington d.c
the democrats have drafted new articles
of impeachment against president trump
and there's an effort underway to
restrict his access to the nuclear codes
house speaker nancy pelosi says trump
could be dangerous in the final days of
his presidency
she's spoken with the chairman of the
joint chiefs of staff about the process
of the nuclear command authority
in a letter to the democratic caucus
pelosi describes trump as unhinged and
said lawmakers must do everything that
we can
to protect the nation from him some
people from the pro-trump mob that
stormed the u.s capitol are being
tracked down and
arrested now including this man richard
barnett posed for pictures with his foot
on a desk in nancy pelosi's office
he was arrested in arkansas on federal
charges of entering and remaining on
restricted grounds
violent entry and theft of public
property today president-elect joe biden
said those who stormed into the building
must be prosecuted a bunch of thugs
insurrectionist white supremacist
anti-semites
6n is not enough i mean come on you know
these shirts they're wearing
these are a bunch of thugs thugs
and they're terrorists domestic
terrorists
canada's prime minister has always
sidestepped directly criticizing
president trump today
that changed justin trudeau says donald
trump incited
the violence what we witnessed was an
assault
on democracy by violent rioters
incited by the current president and
other politicians
president trump has said he will not
attend joe biden's inauguration on
january 20th
biden says that's just fine with him
because trump wasn't welcome anyway
efforts are underway to fast-track a
second impeachment of the president and
the u.s justice department
is not ruling out charging him with
criminal liability for the violence
jackson proskow reports lindsey graham
you are a traitor to the country
the rage of president donald trump's
supporters you know it was
linked he's now directed at republicans
fierce loyalists like senator lindsey
graham face their wrath
for defying trump by acknowledging the
legitimacy of joe biden's win
it's gonna be like this forever wherever
you go for the rest of your life
the chaos extends to the white house
where there is growing pressure on trump
to resign or be removed
for inciting the violent mob that
stormed the capitol with his lies about
a stolen election
to those who engaged in the acts of
violence and destruction
you do not represent our country and to
those who broke the law
you will pay trump's pre-recorded
condemnation of his supporters
included a hint that their fight is not
over our incredible journey
is only just beginning in a stunning
letter to the democratic caucus speaker
nancy pelosi warned that if the
president does not leave
office imminently and willingly the
congress will proceed with
our action that means impeachment pelosi
also says she spoke with the chairman of
the joint chiefs of staff to discuss
available precautions for preventing an
unstable president from initiating
military hostilities
or ordering a nuclear strike 12 days
before trump leaves office
even some republicans have had enough i
believe the pre
the president has disregarded his oath
of office
he swore an oath to the american people
for now only trump supporters face
consequences
arrests of those who stormed the capitol
have begun including a west virginia
state lawmaker
and a man allegedly found in possession
of an assault rifle
and 11 molotov cocktails outside the
capitol
democrats at this hour are now
circulating draft articles of
impeachment they seek to go after trump
for what they call
incitement of insurrection those draft
articles could be introduced as early as
monday for a vote by
wednesday the question is whether they
would pass through the
republican-controlled senate which was
what it would take to remove trump from
office
at least one republican has come forward
tonight i'll ask lisa murkowski
calling on trump to resign so there may
be some votes there
it's a wait and see approach right now
for democrats donna and the stake
stakes are incredibly high
right jackson prosco in washington
thanks now back to the other big story
among those being vaccinated for covet
19 in canada
are several hundred inmates in federal
institutions it's a pilot program that
got underway today
elderly and medically vulnerable inmates
will get the shot
and as abigail beeman explains the
project is not without controversy
i worry for all these guys sherry meyer
is a prisoner advocate with a loved one
serving a life sentence at saskatchewan
penitentiary
the prison has the highest number of
active covid19 cases in the country
72 but no vaccines meyer says because of
that
inmates have been forced to stay in
their cell 23 and a half hours a day
some guys are choosing to
bird bath as they call it in their cells
in their sinks as opposed to
showering every day so they can contact
family is
it's inhumane global news has learned
there are now four vaccine clinics set
up in federal institutions across the
country
all in facilities with zero active covid
cases
in a pilot program for the elderly and
medically vulnerable correctional
service canada says
40 inmates were to be vaccinated friday
and about 600
inmates in total that's less than 5
percent of the federal prison population
this week's tweet from the conservative
leader set off a firestorm calling for
no criminals to be vaccinated ahead of
vulnerable canadians or
line health care workers when someone
becomes seriously ill
in our federal institutions they don't
receive treatment within the institution
they take up an icu bed in the hospital
in the local community
at the very least quite obviously
that should include front-line prison
staff and correctional officers
it's something that our members are
begging for right now the union of
canadian correctional officers is
calling for the federal government to
roll out vaccines in the workplace
but ottawa maintains that's up to the
provinces
inside institutions where distancing is
a challenge so far there have been
nearly 1200 coven 19 cases behind bars
and three deaths senator kim pate
questioned some of the reporting
i would be surprised if it was not
higher i would be surprised if the
incidence is not higher than what we are
hearing as well
as for why prisons with zero active
covet cases were chosen
csu would only say their following
recommendations from the national
advisory committee on immunization
and that's where the elderly and
medically vulnerable inmates live
they tell global news planning is
underway for more vaccine clinics
but they can't say when they'll open in
prisons with active covet cases
abigail beeman global news ottawa
there's a snapshot tonight of how the
economy has been affected by the
pandemic
and it is worse than expected statistics
canada says the economy lost more than
62 000
jobs in december the first decline since
april and more than
double what economists had forecast the
data shows unemployment rose
to 8.6 percent from 8.5 percent in
november
experts warn another month of job losses
could be on the horizon as holiday
restrictions are extended due to the
surge in cases
that have already hampered a fresh start
to the new year
westjet is cutting jobs and slashing its
flight capacity by a third because of
what the airline calls the
instability in the face of continuing
federal government travel advisories and
restrictions
about 1 000 employees will be affected
some will be temporarily laid off others
will be
furloughed or have their hours reduced
the calgary-based
airline is also pulling more than 200
international and 150 domestic flights
from its schedule london's situation
critical coming up how that city is
buckling under the stress of covet-19
plus the huge sinkhole it opened up next
to a hospital
in italy
this happened in a parking lot outside a
hospital in naples italy a giant
sinkhole forced a nearby covet 19
recovery ward to close temporarily
the sinkhole is about 50 meters long and
wide at least
15 meters deep it swallowed up several
cars though the lot was mostly empty at
the time
and no one was hurt in the uk the mayor
of london has declared a major incident
to move normally reserve for terror
attacks or natural disasters
the rate of covet 19 infection in the
city is out of control in london's worst
hit burrows it's believed one
in 20 people have the virus the uk
reported its highest daily toll of the
pandemic today
more than 1300 deaths and 68 000 new
infections in just 24 hours
as redmond shannon reports hospital
staff are barely coping
locked down london is now one of the
epicenters of covert 19.
infections in the uk capital and
surrounding regions have hospitals
on the brink every single member of the
nhs staff is
going through so much i mean you're
everywhere is understaffed everywhere is
getting put through all this we're all
at risk we're all coming into work and
putting ourselves at risk and our
families
staffing is such an issue because so
many medics have become
patients themselves i want to help
i don't know when i'm here as a patient
and helpless the more infectious variant
of the virus
first found in the uk is dominating new
case numbers
mayor sadiq khan has now declared a
major incident
it allows emergency services to
re-prioritize
and share resources a step already taken
in neighboring counties so we've already
diverted some of our fire fighters to
drive ambulances
and over the course of the next few days
police officers
will begin driving in ambulances as well
there are almost 50 percent more covert
patients in uk hospitals now
than during last april's peak one out of
30 londoners now has this
virus but in some parts of london it's
one out of
20. the consequences on the health
service are likely to be felt
long after the pandemic walks the unit
to find
nurses uh crying that the physical and
mental load
is is huge and i'm
really worried that we're gonna break a
lot of nurses
on thursday night the weekly round of
applause for frontline workers here in
the uk
returned for the first time since last
spring however the winter weather
and covert fatigue seems to have
affected participation
but the mayor and medics say if people
really want to help
they should just stay at home donna
all right redmond shannon in london
tonight thanks there has been lots of
debate about whether the second dose of
the pfizer biontech and moderna vaccine
needs to happen within the four weeks
the manufacturers say is necessary
today the head of the world health
organization's european region called on
countries to be flexible with the timing
if they have low supplies of the
vaccines it is important that such a
decision
represents a safe compromise between the
limited
global production capacity at the moment
and the imperative for governments
to protect as many people as possible
while reducing the burden of any
subsequent wave on the health systems
prolonging the gap between doses by up
to 12 weeks have generated
fierce debate among scientists pfizer
and biontech warns
they have no evidence their vaccine
would be as effective
if the second dose is given more than 21
days after
the first boeing owes billions still
ahead the crime and punishment facing
the company over two fatal plane crashes
boeing will pay 2.5 billion u.s to
settle a criminal investigation into two
deadly 737 max plane crashes
the company admitted in court documents
that two of its pilots deceived american
regulators about a key safety system
the agreement does not force boeing to
plead guilty to criminal charges
the 737 max jet was grounded worldwide
for 20 months after two deadly crashes
killed 346 people
including 18 canadians 737 max jets are
still
pending approval for to fly again from
transport canada
today marks a grim milestone one year
ago 176 people were killed when ukraine
airlines flight 752
was shot down by iran's revolutionary
guard
almost half of the victims were canadian
citizens or permanent residents
all of the countries whose citizens died
issued a joint statement today calling
on iran
to provide a complete and thorough
explanation of the events
and decisions that led to the downing of
the plane it also says tehran must
compensate victims families
properly canada has rejected iran's
offer to pay a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars to each of the families
saying
the final amount will be subject to
negotiations
tehran initially denied any involvement
but then admitted its military
shot down the jet after mistaking it for
a missile
next one year after the shooting down of
that plane the pain
is still fresh
a year has barely dimmed the grief of
those who lost loved ones on ukraine
airlines flight 752
and a lack of answers from iran or
anyone being held accountable
is further compounding their grief bara
nasser spoke to an ontario man who lost
his wife
and only son one year ago today
[Music]
one year later is about to eat the last
meal his wife shakiba made before she
left for iran
he kept it in the freezer for this day
the pain so deep and raw for a man who
lost his past
and his future in an instant shakiba
and their only son nine-year-old rostin
died when ukraine airlines flight 752
was shot down by the iranian army this
photo was taken just before the mother
and son
boarded the doomed plane hello everybody
welcome to another video rostin's
bedroom has stayed still for the past
year except for a memorial on the young
boy's bed
i can't go inside it's
the space is so heavy for me i cannot go
in
there are memories in every corner of
the house the family was in the process
of renovating
when the tragedy happened we built this
house of
me and shakib and even russia i make
this fireplace rostin gave me the stone
shackyball gave me the
other tools and i just make it this year
mogadam completed the home
just like his wife would have wanted
down to the wallpaper he had custom made
from the pattern on one of shakiba's
dresses you know i
i driving a lot during the night because
i consciously many times
it's happened to me i see rosting on the
back seat and
i see at the beginning in the mirror and
then when i turn it back
i see no i'm and it's happened
almost every time he received a couple
of suitcases of clothes and books from
the flight's wreckage
but what he really wanted was his wife's
wedding ring when i asked for it
from the from the molds the doctor said
mr mugandan there is no finger for the
ring
so there is no ring what does
justice look like to you everyone
talks about the money about the
compensation
but for us the money is nothing
the justice is the day
which we show those who are
responsible for these terrorist attacks
we see them in court last month would
have been rostein's 10th birthday
which he celebrated without his son his
wife
and without justice farah nasser global
news toronto
and that is global national for this
friday i'm donna friesen
tonight marks the end of a tv era what
is the game show
jeopardy without beloved host alex
trebek we leave you with a look back at
the late canadians
37 years with the show tonight jeopardy
will air trebek's final taped episode
exactly two months after he died from
pancreatic cancer
thanks for watching i'll see you back
here on monday take care of yourselves
bye-bye
[Music]